Relationships,
you know,
they,
what they do is me taking fragile piece
and I actually think that probably works
if you're,
if you're bounded by roles.
And this was a union observation.
So Yoga belief that you didn't have to
have an individual relationship if you
were in a traditional culture because
women did women phase and then did men
things and they walked along the path
in parallel and there were no conflicts
because there were no their word.
But you know,
they're there.
Most of what you were supposed
to do was laid out for you.
And you know,
modern people don't like that idea,
but just trying to go
shooting over who should do,
who should cook dinner,
see if you can settle that before you
make a decision about whether the rules
are useful or not.
Cause you know,
I'd be in lots of houses where that fight,
it'd been going on for 35 years.
Never solved.
So hitch could need neo was,
the food was terrible.
The husband and wife were
at each other's throats,
you know,
fine.
So it's really hard once
you're under the rules to,
once you're out of the rules,
you have to do it as an individual.
But that's a trek,
tremendous demand.
It's an unbelievable demand.
It's the same demand that essentially
the Dostoyevsky put on himself.
It's like we're partners will say,
you are one weird and unwieldy and
malevolent and peculiar creature and so
alive.
So like how the hell are
we going to sort that out?
Well,
you better be awake if you're going to
sort that out and they fuck you all heard
of him is the Gottman situation,
right?
Everything's fine and your heart's racing
and your cordisol is generating and
you know you're having murderous streams.
I've had clients who were very motivated
to commit homicide and they had their
reasons.
One client I'm thinking about,
she thought it was their moral duty to
do this because the person that she paid
it had really hurt their family.
Like not in some trivial way,
but like hurt them as badly
as she possibly could,
but there was nothing
she could do about it.
There was no legal recourse.
And so she was a very moral person.
In fact,
somewhat I would say
it doesn't matter if
she's a very moral person.
This was just driving her crazy.
It's like I have to act,
I have to ask.
I can't just let this person get away
with it because it was also ongoing.
Well,
but what are you going to say?
stop thinking about that.
You know,
you could put your thoughts
to a more productive use.
It's like,
it's not helpful.
You can't,
you can't help a person like
that at all until you put your,
you put yourself in their situation.
You think,
okay,
if I was in that situation
and that had happened,
what would I do?
And then the first thing I thought was,
oh,
I'd be having the same
kind of burgers fantasies.
So that,
that doesn't seem like it's
possible that that's not a great,
so let's see if we can come
up with something else.
But the danger there is that you have
to put yourself in that situation.
And people don't like to
do that because they think,
oh well I'd never have
murdered his fantasies.
It's like if you would never
have murderous fantasies,
I would actually say there's
something wrong with you.
If you're not capable of that.
Then there's like there's
a path of you missing.
It's in there man,
and when and when.
When someone's pushing on you at some
point in your life and they will,
you better have that reserve capacity
or they're just gonna mow you right over
so you could see what this would mean.
It would simply mean that before
presenting your own point of view,
it would be necessary for you to really
achieve the other speakers frame of
reference to understand his thoughts and
feeling so well that you can summarize
them for him.
Sounds simple,
doesn't it?
But if you try it,
you will discover it is one of the most
difficult things I've ever tried to do.
However,
once you have been able to
see the other's point of view,
your own comments,
we'll have to be drastic and revised.
You will also find the emotion
going out of the discussion,
the differences being reduced and those
differences which remain being up a
rational and understandable sore.
Roger's thought that courage was a
prerequisite for empathic understanding.
It's interesting too,
because you know,
here,
here's a,
here's a question for you.
It's like,
should you trust people
or more specifically,
you know,
should I trust you?
Well,
you might think if you've heard me talk,
you'd think,
well,
there's no way you should trust a person
because they're just so full of snakes
and malevolence that it's
just absolutely mind boggling.
So why in the world would you
ever trust something like that?
Well then you can think about it this way.
There's two kinds of trust.
There's the kind of trust you have when
you're too stupid to know better and
that's not trust.
That's naivete.
And that is not a moral virtue.
And there's the kind of trust you have
when you know that the person you're
talking to and you are completely full
of snakes and you decide as an act of
courage that you're going to trust the
person anyways because that of all the
things you could do to help lead them
and the discussion towards the light,
that's the most important.
It's like,
I'm going to assume that you know,
our interactions,
your impulse towards the good
is going to be victorious.
Now,
isn't it?
If you're interested in this,
you could go online.
You can watch Paul Bernardo,
you remember Old Paul Bernardo.
Okay.
There's videos of Paul Bernardo online
when he's talking to a bunch of RCMP
officers and judges.
They're trying to extract
some more information from
him about some murders that
remained unsolved.
You want to see a
psychopath and operation.
You can just watch those videos.
It's amazing.
He,
he runs the meeting like
he's the CEO of Apple.
It's amazing.
So,
and that's a problem,
I would say to some degree
for the Rogerian approach,
right?
Because,
well,
what about Paul Bernardo,
you know,
is everyone fundamentally
oriented towards the good?
Wow.
It's a reasonable presupposition.
Most of the time I think it works
better if societies organize themselves
according to that principal
because otherwise we know,
for example,
that one of the,
you might think,
what's a natural resource
oil,
right?
For a
bauxite or iron ore or
forget about all that.
The fundamental natural resource is trust.
So if you look around the world and
you look at economies like Japan for
example,
Japan has no natural resources,
right?
While they're filthy rich.
Why?
Because of the economy is basically
predicated on interpersonal trust.
So when there's been some lovely work
done in economics regarding precisely
that,
without trust,
your oil just sits in the ground or it
leaks out of the pipelines because nobody
welded them property.
You know,
there,
there isn't,
there's no reason to assume that
you're going to be able to do anything
cooperative or collaborative.
So trust is a necessity.
If you're really willing to
understand a person in this way,
if you're willing to enter his private
world is see the way life appears to him.
You run the risk of
being changed yourself.
You might see it his way.
You might find yourself influenced
in your attitudes or personality.
The risk of being changed is one of the
most frightening prospects most of us
can face.
If I enter as fully as I am able into
the private world of the neurotic or
psychotic individual,
isn't there a risk that I might
become lost in that world?
Most of us are afraid to take that risk.
The great majority of us cannot listen.
We find ourselves compelled to evaluate
because listening is too dangerous.
The first requirement is courage
and we do not always have it.
Okay,
so it says three o'clock on this,
is that right?
Wow.
That's a good place to stop there.